and we got a story now about change for
me and also change inside America's
oldest professional sport talking about
baseball unlike football fields and
basketball courts which are all the
exact same size the dimensions of every
Major League Baseball Field are
different and Major League Baseball
teams can actually change the dimensions
of their ballpark last year in Baltimore
the Orioles for example move their left
field fence back about 30 feet and
almost doubled the height of the wall
and this was news that nearly knocked me
down personally because believe it or
not way back in high school I had
actually hit one over that wall so get
your bets in now because this is a story
about my effort at age 42 to do it again
he's gonna try to come in one of those
heaters the older I get the more my
family has to hear about one fastball
one of the prettiest things I think in
history college baseball to be honest
with you the time I Homeward for George
Washington University against nationally
ranked Tulane for example
or the swing that beat the University of
Maryland in the bottom of the ninth but
of all my tired Old Glory stories
replays of which exist only in my
memories the one I tell the most is me
as a high school senior on the field for
an All-State game at Oriole Park at
Camden Yards where I took a low fastball
into the Left Field seats the couple's
big swing ran the headline in the
Baltimore Sun North is 376 it was right
around there
but as I recently saw for myself the new
Left Field seats at Camden Yards are way
deeper and this simulation from my
so-called friends in the Orioles front
office shows how my big swing from high
school would now be just another Fly
ball there were seats that we just
basically truncated and pushed back
Orioles general manager Mike Elias
doesn't seem to care what he's done to
me he basically took that away from me
now in retrospect if you can bounce one
off the wall here I think that's pretty
good for a high school kid now but it
turns out the old Oriole Park which felt
so big to me was actually among the most
home run friendly in Major League
Baseball for Elias the change came down
to the analytics it was our judgment
that having a very small ballpark where
the ball tended to fly was a
disadvantage for the organization and I
imagine also if you call up a free agent
with these Dimensions who's a pitcher
they answer the phone more red Italy
that's probably the biggest part of it
this was always a really tough sell to
bring free agent pitching into Baltimore
not anymore the 2023 Orioles have one of
the best records in baseball after
signing some of the best pitchers in the
game and to their credit they were also
kind enough to invite little old me back
for a new attempt at a home run what do
you think my chances are of putting one
out of this park 25 years after I did it
as a high schooler absolute zero
tell me what you really think you do hit
a home run here we will sign you to a
professional contract you hear that you
hear that we have witnesses
Orioles catcher adley rutchman was more
encouraged I'm excited to see what you
got any tips for me
as a hitter
um try and go in that corner right there
where it says 376. so aim for the 376
yeah try and go right there why not aim
for the 333 that seems even better you
could try that that's I mean that's
pinpoint all right here we go and so
with my family looking on I stepped into
the box during Orioles batting practice
but wait let's hold that thought for a
moment and talk about change because you
might think baseball never changes that
it's America's great constant but in
fact the game is always changing the
height of the mound the makeup of the
ball the rules for the bat even and as
of this year the size of the bases and
the time allowed between pitches
so you wonder did I do it again
I'm now a 42 year old guy with four kids
and a mostly desk job of course I didn't
one more
oh
baseball changes you remember and so
does ability couldn't even reach the
child out there and whatever I had is
now thoroughly tapped
what you're doing right now doing the
Wham but while I will never ever again
Homer inside a Big League Stadium I do
have some new Glory stories to tell
there's a time I threw out the
ceremonial first pitch inside the
ballpark where I fell in love with
baseball in the first place
and the time up in the broadcast Booth I
got the chance to talk baseball sitting
next to Orioles Hall of Famer Jim Palmer
who is also one of the greatest baseball
broadcasters of all time the actual
voice in my head growing up as a
baseball fan and for once his lineup
card included me you always want to aim
high when you throw out a first pitch
yeah until you did a nice job I've seen
that that angle from the top there I
realized that was not a strike I have to
say you know a left-handed hitter would
have taken that one in the side
maybe the best part of all Palmer razzed
me like an old teammate there we go
that's what black lives also Center
you're happy about that I'm excited that
that was uh if you're a shortstop that's
not playable
and for my wife Katie who's heard all
she can bear of the old story at Camden
Yards
I have a brand new favorite
yeah great that was awesome that was
great thank you so much yeah Mike was so
sure you wouldn't do it Mike Goliath is
kind of a baseball genius he's the
general manager he's on Scouting For the
Astros he took one look at me and he you
know his job is to evaluate talent and
he was like nah he did it on the spot he
was like I thought you had a chance you
know you're my guy so I'm biased yeah I
appreciate that I was like how did it
feel it looks so cool oh it really it
really is a dream come true man the
years kind of fell off me I felt like a
little kid again until my shoulder
started popping as I was swinging I was
like oh I'm not a little kid anymore my
favorite line is Katie going I don't
know what you're doing I don't know
what's happening she's tired of hearing
those stories thank you to the Orioles
and they got a great ball Club this year